[Music]
rose we're so excited to have you here
today thank you for coming thank you
it's great to be here at Stanford it's
just amazing it's wonderful now I'm not
sure if you know this but Patagonia is
practically the unofficial uniform of
GSB students I don't see it around
campus a little bit today in preparation
for this interview I undertook a
rigorous study to analyze how many GSB
wearing I would find in just one day on
campus
okay and so without even trying I found
them in the library in the dining hall
in class in Town Square and everywhere
in between
that's good I even found some GSB
students clad head to toe in Patagonia
in Patagonia so while the GSB students
clearly love Patagonia products what we
love even more is the company's
leadership and values and we're really
excited to explore those with you today
thank you it's great to be here so I'd
love to start with your personal journey
before you found your way to Patagonia
early in your career you reached the
heights of professional success in PE
and in tech yep you were the CFO of a
public company and later the EVP of a
private equity firm yeah and in 2006 we
walked away from it all
I do can you share with us why yeah so I
think like anyone you know when you
start out your career you're sort of
striving you know you're striving to
figure out who you are you're striving
to to do work that is meaningful to you
even though you don't really know what
that is yet and you're just figuring it
out and you know I got to this place
where my Italian immigrant family was
like wow you've made it you know
you're the CFO of a public company I was
in my 30s and and I I was also going
through a spiritual sort of journey I
was studying Buddhism at the time and I
got to a place where my work life felt
completely separated from my personal
life and my values and it seemed to be
that way with everyone that I was
working around it seemed there was a spy
firk ation between your work life and
your personal life and your personal
values and I just couldn't bear that
anymore and then I started working in
private equity because I thought I'd
have more freedom it would be more
exciting and I was really disappointed
by it I know some of you are gonna go
work so I feel kind of bad saying but
but for me personally you know I could
see that that you know the buying and
selling of companies made very few
people rich and in most cases in a lot
of cases hurt the people that were the
actual workers you know and the people
that had built the company so yeah I
went on a sort of personal exploration I
went to India I took some time off it I
took care of my ailing mom at the time
and and I thought about different things
that I could do with my life and I
thought well maybe I should work for an
NGO but then I thought I know nothing
about that and I thought maybe I should
become a Buddhist nun and but then I
thought that's not so great and I I
thought I'd use sort of the skills that
I had which was making people money
being a really good operator being a
good leader a good manager but do
something with it that was more aligned
with my values and I think for many
people this idea of giving up a path
that is safe and conventionally
prestigious feels very scary you
actually did it what did you learn from
that was it as scary as people think you
know it's funny the people around me
that were very trapped in their their
structure we were like calling me and
saying you're doing the wrong thing
you're gone too long you're leaving in
the height of your career I mean it was
like you know there was a lot of advice
and it was all wrong I mean
that's basically what I could say about
that I think that you know once you know
that you want to make a change I think
you start to visualize that you're gonna
make that change and it sounds like
during that time you were reflecting a
lot on what matters to you
what does the outdoors mean to you and
how did that shape your decision to
focus on the environment well nature is
like to me it's it's like a spiritual
experience and it's just an experience
of awe and you know we we don't get a
lot of those experiences I think in our
day to day life and we want to protect
it but I think what was more interesting
to me was that Ivana had this model
where he was basically saying you can
have a great business you can make
quality product but you can also do the
right thing by the environment by your
employees by your community and that to
me was like the most holistic vision of
business that I'd ever seen and I wanted
to see if it actually worked and how it
worked and so that's sort of what
brought me to to Patagonia yeah
absolutely and so you joined Patagonia
which as you mentioned is a company with
long-standing commitment to
environmentalism but under your
leadership the mission has become even
bolder Patagonia is now in the business
of saving the home planet why did you
think it was important to aim even
higher
yeah well that was really yvonne saying
you know we had so fully embodied the
old mission statement that we felt like
the urgency of the climate crisis and
the extinction that we're facing is so
urgent that we just we felt like
everybody's mission every business's
mission should be to save our home
planet I mean we're facing this
extinction you know crisis and this and
we can't turn our head turn away from it
you know and we need we need the rest of
business to sort of wake up and turn
towards solutions and innovations and
the things that will you know will will
help us survive and Evon in some ways
had this pioneering
almost anti-corporate vision of
responsible business and since you've
joined you've quadrupled revenue to
reach over a billion dollars annually
some people might think that driving
both growth and environmental
stewardship at the same time is
impossible but you've seemingly done it
how I don't I don't think that they're
disconnected
in any way I mean I think at the
foundation of the business it's making a
great product and then standing behind
that product so I don't think that is in
any way bifurcated from caring about you
know our planet and our environment I
mean the businesses was founded by
people who you know Yvonne himself made
so many first ascents and climbs in his
life I mean you know there are people
that love the outdoors and saw the
changes that were happening to the
outdoors over time because we keep going
back to these places you can see that
they're you know they're starting to
degrade or they're being destroyed by by
the climate crisis so I think Yvonne saw
that and it's embedded in the company
it's been I think more important in the
last few years because we have so many
climate deniers in our government it's
been more important for us to take more
of a stand and I think our customers
understand that you know and they've
been with a brand a long time and they
appreciate that and one of the unique
things about Patagonia is that in many
ways it's very counter cultural you
donate millions in Black Friday sales to
environmental organizations and you
encourage customers to repair and resell
their gear and so as a leader at
Patagonia how do you decide where to
place these bets on being different you
know it comes out of what's happening in
the moment you know like the when we
donate our Black Friday sales it was
right after the election we were really
bummed out about what was going to
happen to you know the environmental
protections that we had we knew that
the administration was trying to you
know get rid of these public lands
designations that were made we were we
didn't feel very festive that that
holiday and so we decided that we we
wanted to to do something that was
meaningful and since Black Friday is
such a representation of consumerism in
a negative way we wanted it to be turned
into something positive and we also
wanted to support grassroots activists
that were on the ground and needed the
money to help fight some of these
environmental battles and some of these
decisions like the one you just talked
about or the decision for example to not
sell Patagonia vests to companies that
don't share these values seem like they
require some sort of prioritization
between growth and and values of the
company and I think a lot of us are
looking to be leaders that work in that
space where when we're prioritizing both
so how do you actually make those
decisions in practice well I mean we we
keep track you know we we we definitely
look at what could be the impact of of
certain actions but most of the time
were wrong for the better right and and
that's that's typically what happens we
just we just decided last year we gave
away that trump tax cut and this year we
had another you know 10 million - we
felt like to give away in addition but
we thought this year ok we're going to
ask our customers to see if they'll
participate with us and our customers
contributed ten million dollars to
grassroots activists in 17 days and we
said this bar thinking 10 mic dollars we
might not get there but our customers
did it and because there is worried
about the environment as we are yeah I
think that's what's so fascinating about
the model is it seems like some of these
moves will hurt profits but they end up
having because these are issues that are
our issues
they're the issues of our day you know
and you can't turn away from them if
you're business leaders you can't turn
away from them and say oh I'm just gonna
go
a profit and forget about the fact that
the planet is burning you know or the
species are dying or that there's such
gross and equity between you know the
the rich and the poor you know that it's
not going to affect me right I think I
think if you grow numb in that way then
we're probably all doomed you know like
we need to turn toward it and actually
do something and while we're on this
topic of sort of growth and values at
some point if Patagonia continues to
grow its retail business that could come
attention between that and sort of the
environmental mission and so how are you
thinking about the growth of Patagonia's
retail side is that going to continue to
be a focus or on new business models
going to much yeah I mean we'll
definitely there's there's a lot going
on in terms of just resources right so
you know we're not going to have
unlimited amounts of virgin material our
virgin resources we've we've known that
for a long time and have been working on
all kinds of recycled and reclaimed
products because the reality is we're
not going to be able to keep consuming
at the rate we're consuming and still
have a planet so we need to we need to
change the business model and that's
amis like innovation it's really
exciting you know the people that we
have working on that they are stoked
about it they are you know blazing new
trails and building new supply chains
you know and and so I think that's
that's just part of the process of
understanding that you know business is
changing and we need you know we need
different solutions yeah definitely and
part of the innovation Patagonia is
doing is moving into this space of food
and agriculture mm-hmm so could you talk
to us a little bit about how that plays
into this strategy that you were just
yeah so we've always been looking at not
just funding grassroots activism but
looking at solutions you know whether
it's solutions to supply chain problems
or pollution in the supply chain and in
the 90s our founder had sort of an
epiphany about can
cotton it uses you know 10x of
pesticides of most crops synthetic
fertilizers really really terrible for
the environment and you said if I have
to make another shirt you know with
conventional cotton
I'd rather close my business and so we
started working on an organic cotton
supply chain so we've always been
pioneers in in organic and if you look
at you know 99% of the agriculture in
the u.s. is chemical agriculture I'm not
going to use the word conventional
anymore because it's you know it's not
conventional its chemical and that's you
know three or four hundred million
pounds of pesticides and synthetic
fertilizers on on the soil so if you
don't think that's affecting Public
Health biodiversity loss you know you're
kidding yourself so we felt like food
was the best entry way that for people
to really understand that we can use the
soil and we can use the earth as a
regenerator and regenerative organic
agriculture which is just really
techniques farming techniques along with
organic chemical free agriculture is is
the sort of solution I think that we
need to turn toward to get out of this
chemical chemical agriculture model that
we're in we only you know so there's
some estimates to say when they have 50
or 60 harvests left I know it's like it
bums you out right but in some way in
some way like it should also excite the
you know it's it should excite some
ideas about like wanting to change it
and to me those are the innovators and
those are the businesses that will
really make a difference the
regenerators you know we can have a
regenerative economy we're gonna have to
have one you know and and then and the
businesses that are working on it now
will I think be the most successful yeah
absolutely and moving forward do you see
the agriculture aren't being sort of
almost as big if not bigger than I think
it could be yeah and I think you know we
also have said
really strong carbon goals for herself
to be carbon neutral by 2025 in our
total supply chain and it's really hard
to do it but we're working on doing it
and some of that is has to be offset by
sequestering more carbon in the ground
through through different farming
techniques and so we're looking at that
as well but yes to me it's really
exciting it's more about innovation you
know and Patagonia is pioneering all of
these innovative approaches and doing
them well your mission is to save the
home planet and Patagonia can't achieve
that alone and some would ask you know
how replicable is what Patagonia is
doing given that you're so
countercultural long-term focused and
privately owned and what's your strategy
for influencing others in the broader
industry well I think the benefit
corporation movement has been a really
important part of of showing that
business should be responsible to
multiple stakeholders when we became the
first California benefit corporation in
2011 and now there's I think 50,000
companies that are taking the be impact
assessment and over 3,000 that actually
are certified and so I think that's like
that's a nice container that's a nice
model you know I can see the influence
now with you know the business Jamie
Dimon and the business roundtable coming
out and saying there should be more
stakeholders than just the financial
stakeholder it seems to me obvious you
know like that there should be more than
one stakeholder and then you could
balance those things and and you know I
think Patagonia does sort of exemplify
balancing those things yeah and one of
the things I loved learning about
Patagonia is your philosophy on sharing
best practices you share openly and you
collaborate even with competitors in
some cases why do you choose to leave
that way well it just makes you know
because we're not a huge huge company it
just makes other it just just helps
innovations to scale you know if we do
it and the north face does it and you
know it's it helps you know and it's
adopted more widely by
gap or someone else you know it's it
makes a difference and so that's really
the philosophy behind sharing and and
always constantly being innovative about
what's next and what problem to solve
next sustainable consumption
sadly does remain financially
prohibitive for a lot of people and if
the goal is to save the home planet how
are you thinking about so reaching the
wider audience is necessary to attain
that goal well I would hope that there's
enough consumer pressure on brands that
you know people understand that if they
buy a $2.00 t-shirt it was probably made
with slave labor and poisonous chemicals
and you know they think twice about you
know buying that product you know I I
think that as a brand we've always had a
belief that we make a great product will
repair it for you if you need it
repaired and it's broken
so we're in a contract with our customer
that says we want you to keep that in
use longer because with all the
lifecycle analysis stuff we've done over
the years the most important thing is to
keep your stuff in use longer and that's
the most important thing a consumer can
do and so will repair it will replace it
if we can't repair it and we'll figure
out a way to recycle the materials that
you have but you have to you know the
customer has their part of the bargain -
and yeah and the work that you're doing
on warren west seems to be an
interesting piece of this and in the
sense that it's attracting younger
customers customers who perhaps can't
buy some of the new patagonia gear but
they are able to buy some of those yeah
I mean there's definitely that you know
we sell we're selling our used gear
we're sort of you know
making sure that it meets their
requirements for for being in the
secondary market and that does help
attract a younger customer but you know
it's attracting younger customers to us
now is really more activism yeah and the
fact that we're standing up for the
things that they care about your
employees love working at Patagonia so I
wanted to spend a few minutes on the
corporate culture it's not hard to see
why they love it from scaling on-site
childcare to encouraging employees to
hit the waves when the surf is up you
invest really heavily in your people why
do you focus so much on this and what's
the return on investment well let me
just say something about childcare
because I feel like that's probably the
biggest transformational thing for me
personally because I worked in tech
before and I don't have any children so
I didn't really relate to like the kinds
of issues that my employees might have
had you know there were like cappuccino
machines you know foosball tables and
all kinds of cool tech stuff but there
was no place that a nursing mom could go
and nurse comfortably and when I came to
Patagonia I was totally blown away
because there was on-site childcare
there's kids around our campus all the
time which is really great because you
see the future every day and you have a
real connection to your employees
children and the next generation and
that's that motivates me every day I
mean when I see my employees and their
children it makes me think about what am
i doing for the long-term and and you
know we we subsidize our on-site
childcare but we manage it ourselves and
we have the lowest turnover in our
female executives managers employees we
have total gender parity so 50/50
management women and men that comes from
having on-site childcare I believe
because women don't feel like they have
to take a break
from their work and you lose a lot of
women after they have kids because it
just becomes unkind of untenable in lots
of ways and it's not supported and a lot
of working environments so that's why I
think we have a really strong great
gender balance company in that way I
think it makes us make better decisions
and and the ROI on it I've done a thing
you can lift it on LinkedIn on the ROI
there is an ROI on it and yeah I mean I
look at that big campus Apple built and
I'm like why is there not childcare
there that was going to be one of my
questions is why aren't more companies
doing this and is it really as expensive
as people think I don't think I really I
the economic model is not is on there
but it's really not it's really not that
expensive I mean to me it's it's the
benefits far outweigh the costs and you
know we subsidize a portion but it's not
you know it's it's not in any way
prohibitive or to our business and
they've been doing it you know
Patagonia's been doing it since they
were a small company so it's just built
into the business model yeah an
incredible inspiration and I hope that
one that we'll all take with us as
future leaders and implement so if we
zoom out from Patagonia's business and
culture and talk a bit more about your
views on corporate leadership
particularly in the 21st century with
all of the problems that we're facing
under your leadership Patagonia has
become much more political you mentioned
earlier you even sued the Trump
administration for its plans to roll
back public lands
why did you ramp up your political
activism and in the lead up to 2020 is
this something that all business leaders
should be thinking about well I think
we've seen a lot I mean when when the
administration pulled out of the Paris
climate Accord we're the only major
country not in the Paris climate Accord
it's a it's a disgrace and you know you
saw business leaders step up and you
know sign it sign a document saying
we're still in we're in the Accord we're
gonna keep working towards those goals
and I think that was the first time I
was like wow business is waking up and
they're starting to really you know
participate and take a stand and you
know are a reaction to what this
administration has done is I think
proportional given that given that the
company's always been about protecting
wild places and protecting the
environment
you know when Trump signs away three
million acres of public land with a
stroke of a pen we're not going to sit
silent about that and it was you know it
was a definitely a difficult choice to
make to sue the administration but it
was the best choice that we had in that
time and yeah I mean we do it again in a
second and we've sued him over the the
Endangered Species Act and we've you
know we're we're an amicus briefs on a
number of other issues and you know the
Clean Water Act and you know we're not
going to sit by while all the
protections to wild lands are dismantled
you know we're just not going to sit by
and watch that
and I I don't think other companies
should either because a lot of their
they probably be interested to know that
a lot of their employees find a lot of
enjoyment and the outdoors and spending
time with her family's there
and if it's gone because of you know
greedy people then we don't get it back
so yeah I mean it feels proportional to
me I mean people are say to me all the
time you're taking a biggest stand but I
it feels very proportional to the to
what the company has been devoted to
over the last 46 years and what will
keep being devoted to me and you're out
there taking a stand often before anyone
else is and you mentioned that's not
always easy what helps you to actually
act on those convictions for those of us
that are hoping to do that one day as
well yeah well I think that you know
Kris Thompkins who's on our board when I
took the job as CEO said to me you don't
get points for holding back and I
thought that was great advice and so
I've always sort of had that and my my
brain you know we shouldn't hold back we
should we should do what we think is
right no matter what the climate is and
what the situation is and so yeah I
think it's that and I also think you
know I work with just amazing people and
we all have the same values of
protecting wilderness for future
generations and we all care about wild
places you know being around and and if
they're you know if they're not we're
not going to have a world to live in and
on the flip side you have spoken out
against tech leaders for the sort of
refusal to take responsibility for their
impact on society where do you see the
sector falling short and how can we as a
spiring tech leaders be better in the
future well it's okay
think of how much money like the few
like richest tech guys are I'm not gonna
name them by name because you all know
what are they doing like going to Mars
I mean how weird is that I mean our our
planet is like we are in dire trouble
here you know there's there's
unbelievable income inequity
there's unbelievable you know there's a
rise of populism and fascism in the in
the world it's very scary right now
there's there's you know there's a
climate crisis that is affecting
everyone's life and causing billions and
billions of dollars in damage and a few
you know what very wealthy people could
do something really powerful about it
and I don't see them doing anything
I really don't self-driving cars going
to Mars I don't get it you know I don't
get it and I think it's I think it's the
reason why a lot of well shouldn't be
concentrated into a few people because
that's what happens and yeah it's not
gonna make me very proud here but you
know it's just my point of view about it
ya know this is why we like bringing
diverse points of view
you you also have these great thoughts
on the financial system and the ways in
which it's sort of structurally
destroying our planet particularly this
emphasis on quarterly earning yeah and
so a lot of us are going to be going
back out into the business and the
finance world what one call to action
will you have for us on on that well I
do think that like this quarterly
earnings thing is insane I was a public
company's CFO and I saw people just like
sweating out one cent of earning per
share and it's like think about your
life like nothing important happens in a
quarter it's it's like it's such a weird
system you know like developed by
probably just a bunch of people you
wouldn't want to sit and have dinner
with honestly
and and I feel like it's really
destroying the planet you know because
it's a short-term thinking I don't want
to think about like what happened in a
quarter I want to look into the eyes of
my employees child and and say what's
gonna happen in her lifetime I mean you
know and to me it's like the whole idea
of this short-term profit that makes a
you know a few shareholders very rich
it's it's not a good model I mean it
doesn't mean the capitalism is bad I
love capitalism I love the competition
I love the innovation I love the working
together and collaboration and the best
ideas win I love that and that's like
the best part of capitalism and great
products and great services and
disruption and all of that so capitalism
needs to evolve that's all it's like
it's not like necessarily a bad system
it just needs to evolve and it needs to
consider more things than just a
financial shareholder or quarterly
earnings report yeah absolutely and
Larry Fink of Blackrock just put climate
at the center of his annual letter you
know we've seen a lot of talk about
these things in the past do you feel
like we're finally reaching a tipping
point where action is coming I don't
know you know I see a lot of talk and I
don't see a lot of action yet from that
group and we don't have time to not have
action you know when I say there's 50 or
60 harvests left there's a lot of
scientists that believe that when
there's you know when we really look at
the climate crisis and how quickly it's
come upon us and pretty much everyone in
this room has been touched in some way
by fire or flood or you know has some
relative that's been affected and it's
only getting worse so I don't see the
action yeah you know I really I don't
see the investment yet I still see
using the same measures or metrics but
maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm not seeing it
all but I thought we'd turn now to some
of the broader leadership lessons from
your career and trajectory and many of
us in this room at Stanford hope to have
found companies we're known for
attracting aspiring entrepreneurs but
there's this other equally powerful path
of working alongside founders and
helping to scale the vision and impact
which is very much what you've done
alongside Yvonne she nod what's the most
important thing that you've learned from
working with him oh man there's so many
things
well he's completely fearless whenever
he makes a decision he doesn't care what
anyone says or thinks or he's just
completely fearless he keeps going you
know and you might get some noise over
here complaints here there but you know
just he doesn't let it bother him he
just he keeps he keeps moving forward
and and he's he's very self examining
it's really part of the company culture
to live an examined life and all of us I
feel like do that and we're all curious
people and yeah and I think that in
quality he's he always has really really
focused on quality and I think he's
right to always bring it back to that
because at the end of the day we're
selling a product and we want that
product to be the highest possible
quality and we want the relationship
with the customer I'm lucky enough to
have some of our Palo Alto store
employees here today and it's like they
do the really hard work of like
expressing the brand through themselves
as people and that is always been really
important you know aspect of the brand
this idea of living a self examined life
I wanted to ask you about this you have
a strong set of inner values that guide
you and anchored in sort of your
Buddhist and meditation practice that
you mentioned earlier
what role does this play in your
leadership and what advice would you
share with us for cultivating that
sense of self well I think it's really
good always to be self examining and to
be curious about differences and you
know we become so polarized as a country
in so many ways and yet there isn't a
whole lot of curiosity about why people
are different or why they might have
different views and and I think my
practice helps me to be more conscious
of the ways in which I you know I fall
short myself of you know being self
reflecting and and meditation is a nice
tool it really does help you deal when
you're in a high-stress job it's good to
have you know it's good to have some
tools that that work for some people
it's like you know certain kinds of
exercising or whatever but for me it's
it's a real tool to manage my just to
manage my life and to check in on my
decisions and whether I feel good and
right about the decisions that I'm
making for the company and for myself
many of us hoped to make pivots
throughout our career and your pivot
from private equity to Patagonia is an
incredible example how do you shift your
mindset to adapt to the new industry
that you're in without losing the unique
insights that you bring from the
previous one well I think you're all of
your life experience you know it comes
to bear in anything that you do and
that's probably a common theme you know
when you do these talks and yeah I mean
I think that's probably the biggest the
biggest thing is it it's all it all gets
incorporated if you're a person who
lives you know a holistic life and your
life has kind of melded together your
values and your work and your life and I
think that's the best way to live you
know and you have this quote that says
work is where the self meets the world
mmm-hmm which I loved and many of us are
graduating in a few months so what is
the most important thing we can do to
actually find that alignment between
yeah I'll work in our values well I
think I think work is the place where
the self meets the world
because it's where you kind of are
confronted with all these sort of
tensions that you don't have in your
family life you know and you have to
navigate through them in difficult
people or difficult business conditions
or whatever it may be and and you learn
a lot about yourself if you're a curious
person and you know like I've learned I
learned a lot from like the bad bosses
that I've had I learned more probably
from the bad bosses than I have from the
good bosses you know there are things
like that that in retrospect when you
look back on it you realize oh yeah I
like didn't ever want to be like that or
I did you know I want to incorporate
this or that or yeah I mean I think yeah
I think that's that's sort of the way I
see it yeah absolutely well we wanted to
leave time today for questions from the
audience so I'm going to turn it over
now to some audience members who have
questions for you great I am Maya grant
and I'm an MBA too and then also doing
the Masters of Science in environmental
studies so if we want to save our home
planet we need to get a heck of a lot of
people involved but the environmental
movement is often associated with a
certain demographic often wealthier
often white and frequently women so what
is Patagonia doing and what can we do as
Future Business Leaders to push that
movement to a greater representation and
kind of include more people in the
narrative yeah
I think that's a really good point it's
a really good good question so what we
started doing this a few years ago with
with our our grassroots giving because
that seemed like the fastest way that we
could activate it and we started just
looking for groups that were outside of
our normals sort of outdoor cohort you
know and and a lot of these
relationships formed over time with just
because Yvonne met people along the way
and they were protecting certain places
and so that's sort of how the movement
grew and and so we took it more into
protecting area
that maybe aren't the grand outdoor
places but it's a cool group of you know
latina moms in LA that are doing you
know that are doing air quality testing
like we wouldn't have even known about
that group before you know and so we
started just bringing in these we
started having kind of conferences with
all these different NGOs and and just
just like making more connections
because we're all really connected in
the same movement and it's just about
like making the connections stronger and
deeper and I think that's the way that
we're looking at it and we're also you
know exchanging sharing learning a lot
from from that process as well so hi
guys
thank you for being here my name is
Ellery and I'm also a second year I'm
organizing the climate conference with
Maya so I'm very excited about this
topic and given Patagonia's 2025
commitment to being carbon neutral and
the complicated history of carbon
offsets
how does Patagonia think about choosing
office offsets that truly deliver when
they are honest and then secondarily how
can we collectively hold Patagonia and
other companies like Microsoft and
JetBlue to the commitments they make
yeah this is a really good question
because like when I first looked it up I
did I didn't really know much about
offsets but when we first started
looking at offsets as a part of our
carbon plan someone told me I could
spend a hundred thousand dollars and I
could offset all of our you know all of
our carbon in the US and I was like that
makes absolutely no sense to me like
just in a practical level that makes
zero sense I don't know where that
hundred thousand dollars is going but it
doesn't seem to be going for what it's
you know really going for so we're
really looking for like absolute
reductions you know by implementing like
implementing solar grids or working on
energy deals or working on converting
factories that are using coal to using
renewable energy and that's the way
we're we're looking at it offsets
there's some offsets that are that are
good they're they're they're
conservation mostly conservation related
the stuff that we're looking at and I
find that to be a little bit you know to
make more sense because conserved land
a carbon sink and it really you know if
it's not conserved it's likely to be
disrupted and destroyed but the market
itself is you know you I think you have
to be very careful about how people get
to that goal and are they getting to it
in a real way so just just keep asking
those deep questions because you know
that's how you hold people accountable
really you know I rose thanks for being
here
I'm Carolyn Lane a first year MBA
student and I have a question about kind
of the global ambition of Patagonia
because we all know Pentagon is in the
business of saving home planet and it's
such a global crisis and imperative
especially for the developing countries
where you you're we're gonna see you
know another bill in middle class
entering the world stage when 2025 so
what is the vision and ambition for
Pentagon yet on the global stage do you
see more aggressive expansion of their
global footprint and how do you balance
that with your anti growth strategy yeah
so it's not really about growing our
footprint so much is like activating our
community in outside of the US region
and we've been in you know we've been in
Japan for almost 30 years we've had a
business in Europe from us 30 years and
in South America and Australia and and
in all those places what we're trying to
do is first of all give to grassroots
organizations that are really doing
things on the ground and that creates
kind of a community for us to work with
and it's one of the biggest changes that
I feel like in my tenure CEO I feel
really proud of is making that mission
much more global and and we use a tool
that we introduced a few years ago
called Patagonia action works which are
now launching around the globe and it
really is to connect our customers with
our causes because a lot of our
customers just want to know what can I
do like you know can I donate time
should I donate money what are the right
NGOs and so we're connecting them
together and it's been really powerful
and
we we also work on policy issues with
with the government you know wherever we
are environmental policy issues and we
stand up as a voice for that and and a
lot of our industry is also concerned
about these issues so we work as a
convener to kind of make change so we
have time for more questions from the
audience so if anyone else would like to
ask Rose a question please throw up your
hand and we will get a mic to you hi
rose I'm Isabel Fisher a second year MBA
student here um I came to do my MBA
because I really do believe the private
sector has a big role to play in
addressing challenges that face the
world however I'm also very aware that
there are certain areas and certain
challenges where the private sectors
role is limited and I'd love to hear you
speak a little bit to where you see that
distinction lying and and where you see
a real role for government nonprofits at
the private sector yeah address well
there's a lot of hybrids going on right
like we we know we noticed this whenever
we have to build a supply chain that
hasn't been built before it's like you
need sometimes you need an NGO sometimes
you need you know a policy person in
government or local government and then
sometimes you might need venture fund
money you know so there's a lot of like
interesting hybrids going on and I think
that's really the only way we're going
to solve these big intractable you know
problems is by collaborating in that way
and you know it it means a lot even if
you're a small business you know it
means a lot if you let your voice be
known to your you know to your
legislators and to the you know become
active in your in policy essentially so
hi earth thank you for being here I'm
gonna teach a first year MBA you
mentioned a lot of success cases where
Patagonia is able to collaborate with
other NGOs with the consumers even with
governments to join the cause what are
the biggest struggles that Patagonia is
facing when you don't succeed in doing
so well I think I think the biggest
struggles are just that trying to trying
to help people understand the scope of
the problem because a lot of
environmental problems you know you can
say well we're going to deregulate you
know roundup but most people don't think
about what are the impacts of that you
know it's like well that might help a
farmer if you deregulate right but what
does it do to this stream and then what
does it do to the water supply and then
what does it do to biodiversity into the
animals that are gonna drink that water
you know it sounds like people have a
hard time in some ways thinking about
the causation of certain policies
especially I think that's probably the
the most complicated challenge is is
like understanding that there might be a
business purpose but there is also like
a better way to do things and you know
trying to always look at that I mean we
we pollute we're you know we're company
we pollute but we we also understand
that that's a problem so we charge
ourselves a 1% tax on our own sales and
we give to environmental groups that you
know will will fight for these causes so
you know I think you constantly have to
be business has to keep in mind that
they have a stakeholder which is the
planet and that is a really hard concept
for people to get I don't know why
because we're losing biodiversity at an
enormous rate right now you know we're
in the middle of a climate crisis I
don't know why that's such a hard
concept but it kind of is I mean you
know it's interesting maybe that's
something you guys will solve okay we're
taking one last question
hi thank you so much um it is awesome to
have an openly queer business leader
honesty today I'm wondering if you could
share a little bit about some mentors
who have helped you get to where you are
particularly as somebody who is out in a
space where there are not a lot of
people who are out well I you know I
wasn't out early in my career because it
was like not you know it was so not cool
to do that and then when I came to
Silicon Valley and I was became CFO
general magic I was like I cannot go
into this very public role you know
because of your CFO you're on all the
road shows and things like that and not
be myself like I just decided I was
drawing a line like I'm not doing it
anymore and and when I told our head the
head of HR when they were making the
offer to me when I told that of HR she
just looked at me and said oh my god I
thought you were gonna say you were had
cancer and and she goes oh you mean this
is you know it was Silicon Valley you
know it was like a very welcoming
community you know but um but yeah I
mean I think I definitely I mean I had a
boss early in my career that asked me
not to act so gay you know in meetings
you know I mean I've had weird stuff
like that happen at my career and you
know but it's just it's like you you
just sort of evolve and you you go
through it you know right now it's just
it's just such a part of me I don't even
think about it until you mentioned it
actually so we usually end our talks on
a lighthearted lightning round
and for this one I thought we could get
the audience involved so we're going to
play a quick game of Patagonia workforce
policy trivia so I'm going to share a
series of policies all of which are true
or false and I'd like the audience to
just yell out whether you think that
true or false and then Rose if you could
reveal the right answer okay I hope I
know it
yeah critical part of the game okay so
number one employees at Patagonia get
every other Friday off true or false
Oh mixed I thought this was the easy one
true true true our corporate office not
in all of our services true we have
other ways of doing it
Patagonia sponsors two months of paid
leave for employees to volunteer with an
environmental organization Patagonia has
a buyback program under which it
purchases all North Face clothing from
new hires forceful but maybe a future
policy how to go in your pays for its
nursing mothers to bring their baby and
a nanny on business trips true amazing
Patagonia subsidizes the installation of
solar panels in all employees homes ok
two more Patagonia rotates its annual
retreats through the US national parks
might not be a bad idea and Patagonia
post bail for employees that are
arrested for peacefully protesting the
environment
at this point we can all understand why
it's so difficult to get a job at
Patagonia Rose thank you so much thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]